thank you  oh nice  oh yeah Giles nice which does nice David  that's dope it's like that I've never  thought about see and now I'm like a  king named I know what sort of King  Giles that is that's some James Bond if  you're a king reveal your name the chip  wardens in the third I put a lot of  thought into that they put the hands on  their ways while they tell you to go  slay the dragon or catch that bandit so  um this is a stance of an empty seat  it's gotten that to the third yeah you  happy when you wake up  papaya  I'm kind of amazed I don't think this is  Kurt unless I have somebody else to do  this well one time  Goldman came and  very happening  so what do you want that for living  around there all of us  there was much  I'll be balling out my mind people just  come here just to exactly is $8 no  maintenance is one security guard hell  yeah oh you [ __ ] don't even  know about me get home from here